every Thursday our series we call it a
more perfect union aims to show what
unites us as Americans is so far greater
than what divides us this morning we've
got the survey young college student
who's overcoming poverty and hardship
with the help of a stringed instrument
Eddie James is his name he plays lead
cello in the Jordan Mason University
Orchestra
he says he's discovered his talent quite
by accident chip Reid visited James on
the Virginia campus to learn about this
life-changing passion what is happening
to you I mean mostly it's just kind of
me trying to ignore the fact that
there's hundreds of people in front of
me for twenty year old Eddie Adams the
cello has been an instrument for much
more than music
I would stay after school and practice
for however long and then would take the
like the after school bus home just to
Eisley spend as much time as I can being
I guess away from reality the cello
takes you away from reality yeah he
struggled with a difficult home life and
at times lived with his family in a
shelter i disremember it was kind of
weird especially having to take the
school bus from the homeless shelter in
junior high school he discovered the
cello by chance they like had us go
around and try different instruments
right on different then I tried
percussion and they said I had no rhythm
so then I ended up not playing
progression and they were like oh we
need people in the orchestra and then
that was like the first time I saw I was
like I don't want to do this but he
persevered with the help of cello
YouTube videos and encouragement from
people like his high school music
teacher
Gerald folks at the time I mean this was
his escape was music he became so good
so fast that George Mason University
offered him a full tuition scholarship
even though he had never had a private
lesson he has talent enormous talent the
director of stringed instruments at
George Mason June Wong says Adams
audition was special I remember that
moment because it's unique when you hear
music come from the core of somebody the
silent peaceful middle of someone and I
felt honored to witness that when he
didn't have one of his own Wong Glen
Adams her cello I believe we are mandate
as human beings to lift each other and
to bring each other's gifts forward and
that's really all I'm doing and he made
beautiful music on my terrible cello
for Adams simple deeds like those have
been life-changing
I feel like thank you isn't enough to
really describe how I feel and I feel
we're just even saying thank you because
I feel like it's not adequate enough to
all the people what does the cello mean
to you everything because it's kind of
gotten to me everything that I have now
and gotten to me to where I am today
that got me into school and I never
thought my saw myself being in college a
sound success where the opportunities
are endless chip Reid CBS News Fairfax
Virginia
[Applause]
Bravo to Eddie James YouTube and no
private lesson and he does that I mean
oh it's about June saying I believe we
are mandated as human beings to lift
each other and to bring each other's
gifts for us it's beautifully told
nicely done shipmate I love that story
and then she said his music comes from
the silent peaceful middle I want to I
want a vacation house in the silent
peaceful middle don't we all or and or
Eddie James in his cello bringing it to
you very nice